good morning guys it's
the morning
still early like sevenish
and we got monkey mama
hanging out she doesn't feel that good
still i know
remember yesterday i was like i feel so
funny so like i felt funny throughout
the day and it was time to go to bed and
i was tired
didn't have caffeine or anything like
that i think taika's calling yeah i hear
our son so
i spoke too soon because what i was
about to say is this is my favorite part
of parenting where ty is a little bit
more autonomous but if i leave him alone
for more than like five minutes and he
gets worried but this guy's watching his
favorite movie of course
eating his favorite food cake and he's
all bundled that looks so cute
what's going on monkey are you done
come upstairs mama's waiting for you
mama's gonna take care of you
hey
that's spider-man
come upstairs duty duty
that's peter b parker
yeah so i had cake with uh
raccoon you're paused it
this fool
knows how to use the apple tv remote
that's insane i don't know if i'm proud
or if i'm
embarrassed
oh let me take her babe off yep
so yeah mama doesn't feel good so i do
have a private jiu jitsu list today
usually me and mama do it two times a
week but since she doesn't feel good she
doesn't want to pass anything on just in
case
or just over exert yourself and
um
get sick so it'll be just by myself
which is why
the young tykes is going up to mama's
room so that mama can
watch him while i learn jujitsu can you
get your little baseball butt up there
get your little baseball butt up there
please what's that
what are you but steph we're doing
that
and since bomb it doesn't feel good i'm
gonna make her
some of this lemon ginger tea and i
really like this if you have access to
like an asian store probably
specifically korean or japanese
they got like this um
almost
lemon and ginger tea like a preserve or
almost like a jam
but it's not really to be used on
sandwiches it's just like a to me at
least it feels like a fresher form and
it feels more potent compared to
something like this because we have
lemon ginger tea here but when it's
dehydrated it just doesn't come out
as thick and then you know when you eat
something with ginger like it feels like
warm and it warms you up this one feels
like this
and i always talk about this but if you
guys in terms of the light
but if you guys don't have one
i mean if you're if you grew up in a
super asian household
probably have one of these guys which is
kind of ironic because my dad is super
asian but he doesn't have one
um this is so
useful because it's boiling hot water on
tap
instant noodles tea coffee whatever you
need and i'm gonna make mama yummy
tea
see all you gotta do
is
get a big spoonful of this guy
and what's dope is you'll see like
actual lemon and ginger chunks in there
which makes me feel like it's like
better for some reason
get a little bit of that in there
and then
instantly
you're able to make tea
and someone could drink it like piping
hot
rather than having the tea like soaked
and then wait a while
there we go
look at that
[Music]
i made your mama some tea watch out it's
hot careful
it's really hot
yeah
here mama cuny
it's gonna make you feel better
thanks duty peppa
what about me
you want ginger tea no what
oh thank you dr kwan
hey you're gonna be a doctor
yeah
how ironic is that imagine he became a
doctor
i rebelled and then i want him to be an
artist and he rebels me
is it yummy
oh
it's really hot oh oh oh my god what the
heck
remember i told you last night you're a
mess
today is a confirmation of that
oh my god how old are you this is
ridiculous
i don't feel good
fine i'm sorry
okay
oh my goodness
oh my jesus
that was hot are you okay you're burnt
you said doesn't taste good after you
even even after you just said it's
really hot
well you also like hot stuff
i know i don't know mama doesn't like
that journal
oh that's gingery
but it's good it's gonna be good for you
yeah
you can't believe i just did that and
you cut it on camera i can't believe it
my chest is burning i'll lick it later
since mambo wasn't feeling good
i got our whole jiu jitsu set up this
morning already
usually what we do is we unroll this mat
and we pull out mama's car
and i set up this little heater and yes
it's tiny but surprisingly it works
really really good
and when me and mama are training when
tyka doesn't have school
we'll set up like the chair
and his little desk as you guys have
seen and i'll put this heater like right
next to them and since this is mesh the
heat just comes right through it and
sometimes they'll actually tell me
papa's really hot and they'll move away
from it but the garage
feels manageable it actually feels
warmer in here than it does inside and i
gotta get
some gum
for
fujitsu
and you know what's really funny about
that jiu jitsu is a combative sport
right like you're trying to strangle
each other
but i actually get ready for jujitsu as
if i'm going on a date like last night
made sure i took a legit shower so i
feel clean this morning and so if i
sweat i don't smell i just brush my
teeth
because i drink some coffee
and then now i'm going to um
get a piece of gum so if i get all up
and close and personal with my coach
i don't stink up his face and i don't
know why this isn't working
uh-oh
uh oh
this is a spare key
i keep the gum in there so that's why
i'm out in the car
gum
success
so funny i'm like hey coach
you're ready for some
and then now change to my ghee
shout out to hyperfly
they sent me the sick
sick ghee
and i love it i love like the super
clean ones or it looks more traditional
but it's still like a modern cut you
know because the traditional geese i
think they're more like judo style and
you'll notice like the jiu jitsu have
kind of like a
a different shape
and the problem with the newer jiu jitsu
is they got patches all over almost like
a
nascar uniform you know like a nascar
race car driver
so
i like hyperfly because
they have a lot of more clean designs
but with the new shape
see how clean it is it's just like white
and silver white and gray
and i'm doing a big no-no right now
which is
standing on the floor with no sandals
and then later going on the mat which
means i will have to
wipe my feet because
you know what jiu-jitsu your face will
go where your feet is
so it's really important to
oh no
no
my belt loop
got washed out ah good not too far back
thank god
that would have been a nightmare
especially with like only 10 minutes
before my coat shows up
so here we go
tie it up
and let me show you guys something a
really cool knot i learned
um it's called the hollywood knot i
believe
because traditionally if you did
taekwondo karate or judo there's a very
specific way to tie it
but i think through the trials and
tribulations in jiu jitsu
we found a new way to tie a knot
that not only looks doper
but also
doesn't come out as much
through rigorous use
so this part's the same where you find
the middle of the belt you put it behind
you
that part's the same all of this
so far the same as a traditional
judo
or karate knot
this is the part that's different
so
you do you tie all the way up here right
that's the same
now what makes this different is you
take that usually you would have went
like this and tied it here
and that would have been simple but now
with the hollywood knot you take this
bottom one
you put it in between
right
and then you take this one and you cross
it in here
through down here
so now when you tie it
it forms this really cool diamond
and it's tucked in
so it almost like kind of like pulls on
itself almost like a square knot
so it's really hard to come out
and yes i know i'm still a wipeout
which is not bad
i do want to pick up a belt
but not unless my coach thinks i'm ready
and to be honest i'd rather spend like a
few years being a really seasoned white
belt
and
really build a strong foundation before
i start progressing because the last
thing you want is to get promoted fast
right and then when you start traveling
and you stop by your friends gyms
and you start getting tapped out by the
lower belts and people are like wait are
you really that belt because you don't
last the test of time
so
i don't mind and i've only been doing
jiu jitsu for three months on and off
uh with privates haven't really been
able to jump into too many classes just
yet so
i'm definitely patient about that
which one
yeah
where you're looking at
[Applause]
[Music]
do you feel tightness somewhere that's
nice
is
all right
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
is a
stagnant position
so it can stall things out if he wants
to get to an alternate finishing
position sometimes you better take a
step back sometimes you got to give it a
little uh leeway to give you the engine
so now he'll have
[Applause]
right
[Music]
[Music]
these triangles are dangerous
this is where your phone started
[Music]
[Applause]
[ __ ]
[Applause]
[Applause]
hey
uh
pick up my
[Music]
oh man
yeah
oh
you're not trying to keep your elbow
knee connected don't let that separate
because it's going to try to shoot
triangle see good grips
[Music]
yes
stay on top and roll
[Music]
can't believe it
yes
[Music]
and that's why i love jiu-jitsu did you
just see i got my ass kicked
by a 130 pound 17 year old
like 20 times in like five minutes and
that's what i love about it because it's
something that anyone can do
and it's using technique to beat
strength and aggression i believe a
helio gracie the guy that started jiu
jitsu he has a saying he says jiu jitsu
is the triumph of human intelligence
over brute strength
freaking love it and uh it's always good
to get your ass handed to you great way
to start today and uh joe just came over
and we're gonna have him on the next
episode of get close so make sure you
stay tuned for that
i
look who's back in town the crooks are
back together again oh cute
what's up cute little bastards they're
crooks why how cute you guys have a
little name together i don't know i
didn't even know we were called i know i
didn't know i just made that i just made
it up right now i like it
we're the crooks yeah
[ __ ] cute bastards what's going on do
you guys have a secret handshake
yes
that's just pulling each other okay
oh you pull yours
double pulling what are you what are you
doing you pulling your like i do this
what do you say
yeah
yeah for nasal decongestion and erectile
decongestant yeah yes it's just that you
would just want to expel everything from
all the [ __ ] holes yeah i get it
we're gonna tell joe i was gonna brief
him on uh what we're gonna film yeah
breathe him oh wow you guys prep we
tried to a little bit a little bit yeah
we're not that organized like this
[ __ ] arm's falling off right now but
so the first video we're just gonna
we're just gonna vibe okay we're just
gonna get down we're gonna connect again
okay um because i haven't seen you in
[ __ ] forever i know you haven't been
on jk news at all i know you guys fired
me and [ __ ] pretty much i'm on the
firings for you guys if you're wondering
why jk news is failing i'm tiring
everybody i don't give a [ __ ]
and it's careful boy's not careful girl
we don't want any girls to come around
anymore too no except for like shannon
boudreau cat the cool girls yeah sherry
you know
never after yeah if they're not
available you can come yeah
tight i'm [ __ ] free
um okay so the first video that's that
so chill as [ __ ] the second video um i
go to instagram and i just tell fans to
ask you questions oh cool they have fun
questions all right let's do it
sounds good all right after the podcast
i have to take joe to my favorite shabu
spot in vegas
it's called chanco and i got the kimchi
which is like a almost like a kimchi
jjigae broth that's a meat
what'd you get joe i got sukiyaki
as you can see it needs to be boiled
and then monkey cheeto got his favorite
food in the whole universe
hannah got kimchi
what do you have there mama korean yeah
that was really cool what yeah so there
are these vans that i don't know what
the addition of it is but i thought it
was really cool the korean pride edition
it says
and it says
the wall
oh really yeah that's cool
i don't know what that means
that's cool
i don't know what that means
oh
oh put the wall oh this is off the wall
off the wall
that's dope put the wall like up
the
wall that's cool and this is ben
good job
a little bit of korean i know
so i thought it was really cool
oh
snap what we got here what we got here
all right so one of our favorite ghee
brands hyperfly sent us a christmas
present it says merry christmas
love hyperfly and they know that the
whole family has been training jiu-jitsu
now oh yeah so they sent our family a
whole little package
really excited yeah
look at this
quan fam love hype that's so cute that
we all train i
know whoa look at this whoa that is a
cool color scheme let me see that green
this is a little small one that must be
taika are you sure yeah oh is this like
glitter oh it's a plastic whoa what is
this
cool material
whoa
look at that purple oh yeah this one's
for sure i feel like this one's mine
this one because it looks like big
medium small and i'm excited because
they told me that they sent a specific
female cut ghee is it like a new thing i
think so i think a lot of it is unisex
yeah so i'm actually really excited to
see how it feels imagine there's only
holes in the nipples
and in the veg yeah
and he's oh see look
oh [ __ ] this is tight you know what this
is what yep
and gray is dull is it a pink floyd
collab
starlight i don't know maybe
this is dope gray ghee with a white belt
that's fine i mean i think it looks
better with black
but it is what it is
no with the black belt oh you're not
gonna see that in the long fault yeah i
know i may never see it you may never
see it exactly so it's this one what
size is this yours female see my four oh
[ __ ] how do you know i'm before i told
them their sizes like you're like 511
whatever it is yeah
whoa black with purple on the inside
that's sexy
damn that's
mine's pink floyd too
yeah that's cool
all right let's see what
tycoons oh my god i'm cute
dude we're the fliest white belts out
there we have so many keys
oh what what
wait is
but there's a little design there let me
see why am i so excited for tykas to
vote because he looks cute as hell
taika
look look it's yours it's green
come check it out
what
they just gave this to you
do you know what logo this is
wow
look at this ghee is so cool
look at that dude
wow
but let me see
oh my god dude
wow this looks you look so good wow this
looks so good look at yourself and look
at the pants there's the pants
hey good job
yeah take it off go go play your game
okay
that looks fresh
walk then that's like always a good
material
how does it feel does it feel too bad it
feels thin no it feels perfect is it
supposed to be smaller no if it's good
yeah that's sick
nice
still going to get tapped out by me
though
a lot because um you've been training
for how many years like you wrestled in
high school no no that doesn't count
none of that counts i've been training
under
under the same coach with you as the
exact same amount of time you even have
a stripe on your whiteboard that you
don't want to admit nope but yeah no no
nope i still catch you i surprise you no
you never know you don't catch me
nothing no all i ever we've been
training
i i was a ballerina i was a dancer yep
um
yep you should be ashamed of yourself
and i played volleyball no contact
sports but yet i'm still keeping up with
no you're not no because today i learned
extra because someone didn't go to class
they didn't feel good and guess what i
didn't feel good i got some secret moves
that you know nothing about
it 104 dude nah you know that that
school has their own secret names
but you do look good
hyperfly